it's time for drew's news the good news
penny
in your good news loafer
and with me at the desk is a man with a
staggering loafer collection rossi moss
mata thank you for noticing
there you
that that go really barking really i
really
lifted my leg up there i didn't know i
could do that
hi everybody hi hi drew that was like
anatomically
like challenging yeah i'm gonna feel
that one tomorrow
all right you ready to get into the news
i am ready all right first up we're
going to talk about dating but we're
it's thrifty week so we're talking about
dating costs you know singles are about
back out there now
only they're finding out that dating
girl it's not cheap can anyone relate
yeah everyone they we got used to zoom
dates but whining and dining person that
cost some moolah and real simple reports
a new survey found 75 percent of daters
they plan to spend how much you think on
a first date
50 60
they say 100
is what they yes rachel right there she
was like
a hundred dollars yeah but i guess
that's what it costs if you think about
it i mean i like an appetizer
[Laughter]
i don't have to think about it you oh
really i'm single oh oh
i thought you meant that you've got on
so many dates you knew how much it cost
i do go on dates occasionally it's fun
um
but um
i guess i haven't thought about what it
cost
well the experts say that if you want to
be conscious about your money with
dating you should
set a dating budget at no more than 10
of your monthly income that is so
romantic okay and
but i mean i guess it's smart but
uh they say you hear some ideas too
there's some thrifty dates you can do so
if you don't have a bunch of money you
get creative you could go get a coffee
you could go browse a bookstore um you
could check out an art gallery some are
free on certain days um i i'm just
laughing over here because i'm like you
know it's also really budget-friendly no
second date
[Applause]
it's very economical oh this was fun but
perfect bye-bye you know what else is
cheap netflix and chill if you know what
i mean
you already got that subscription or
your friend's password exactly if you
want 20 other people sharing it
um how many like
people here show of hands like want a
big sort of elaborate
thing on their first date
not a lot of hands that's interesting
maybe it's not about money but it's
about gesture like you know what i mean
if you want to take me somewhere special
show me something that means something
to you i don't care if it's zero dollars
how many people are like cool with a six
pack and a ferry ride or a walk in the
park and coffee yeah i'm
i i went on a date um and i ate pizza on
the curb and i was like this is perfect
and we went and saw a movie and i was
like great what about going dutch do you
ever do that where you split the bill on
a date
that gets weird does it
i just heard some weird scuttle butt
from the audience with the guests why
hmm there's something does anyone raise
a hand wanted to say why they were
coming i see you with a giant flower
over there please and thank you i am
feeling that flower one second one
second gosh oh my god and i'm on your
t-shirt
[Applause]
oh my goodness
well
now i've lost what the question even was
well it was about going dutch oh yeah so
i'm dutch so i just know that i need to
go dutch all the time i'm also a
feminist so i love making sure that
my date doesn't have to pay you get to
know someone better that way see i have
no problem with like i would love to
treat a man and i think women should
open doors for men i think chivalry
should totally go across gender heck yes
um
and there's probably an occasion where
you can be like we got this together and
it like flows but i feel like it can be
a record scratch moment when the bill
comes yes yeah it can get awkward uh-huh
well thank you and thank you so much for
coming and wearing flowers
okay well sticking with the thrifty
theme we've got another thrifty and
sustainable combo the daily mail reports
that there's a new time-saving trend
making the tick-tock rounds the next
time you go grocery shopping instead of
paper or plastic try a laundry basket
that's right you can use it to shop then
check out and just load it on back
into your car plop it down then you can
take it out and throw it right back in
your house and this solves the old like
soups can roll around problem or the bag
breaking who's in for this
huh
um
you you love this i
live for a laundry basket
i love
laundry i know you do it's so weird i
love it i love it um i i okay i kind of
get how this works i i don't know that i
i don't know i'll try this but i will
tell you this i do hate paying the 10
cents for a bag at the grocery store so
i'll do i mean even here in the city
i'll do whatever it takes to avoid it so
i will carry like garbanzo beans tuna
fish a bottle of fresca i will carry it
eight blocks just to avoid carrying a
bag so maybe i should just bring a
laundry basket
all right well finally you know all week
long we've been rolling up our sleeves
and trying out nifty thrifty tips and
tricks in
let's get thrifty
is that a drill and a pig smooth you
better better believe it
today we're adding power tools to the
game with our pumpkins we're gonna drill
a pumpkin let's i'm a safety kind of guy
so let's put this on and thank god it
coordinates with my outfit okay good
today we're gonna drill a pumpkin that's
right are you
[Applause]
ready housekeeping
good housekeeping reports your household
drill can make the perfect pumpkin
carving tool no need to buy any fancy
carving tools every year i buy one of
those pumpkin carvers and the next
halloween i'm like where did that go
well now we don't need it look
okay
here's a pumpkin and you know you can
get these like grids where you kind of
follow and you take one of these little
toothpicks and you sort of poke right
like a stencil like a stencil and then
you can either drill right through the
paper or you can mark it with the
toothpick and then remove the paper
and get your drill on yeah but i'm going
to go right in are you ready okay let's
get drilling okay
oh
[Applause]
this is sabotage drew barrymore sabotage
[Applause]
okay well it seems like a great idea
when it works um i think also we need
what are we drilling with this look at
the hole
i don't know this is the wrong size
i think it might be the wrong people
[Music]
you